the oldest DNA that's been recovered has
been from a bone a horse bone that was
preserved in frozen ground in the Arctic
for about seven hundred thousand years
and the only reason that DNA survived
for this long was because the ground in
which that bone was preserved was frozen
for the entire time
we think that DNA can only survive for
somewhere around one to two hundred
thousand years this means that things
like dinosaurs which one extinct more
than 65 million years ago are not within
the range of surviving DNA one thing
that we would really like to understand
is how species and populations and
ecosystems are going to respond to the
climate change that is predicted to
happen today and in the future what we
can do with ancient DNA is we can watch
species like mammoths and bison and
horses actually experience past periods
of rapid warming and we could ask how
they responded why does some species go
extinct and others not the Arctic is an
ideal place to investigate this because
there are thousands of bones that are
incredibly well preserved that contain
DNA so we look for fossil remains
anywhere that the permafrost is melting
another rich source of fossil bones is
at active placer mining sites in the
Klondike in Yukon placer mining is a
type of gold mining that uses
high-pressure water that is actually
sprayed against melting layers of
permafrost but as they're washing away
this frozen dirt thousands of bones are
exposed these bones are an absolutely
rich wonderful resource for genetic
material and we take them back at the
lab to extract DNA we have to be very
careful with the DNA itself we work in a
clean lab we dress in crazy outfits that
make it look like we're working with
incredibly dangerous material but in
fact we are the danger to the material
it's our DNA that might get into these
extracts that could contaminate these
samples for a long time there was very
little hope that we would be able to
recover complete genomes from
like mammoths and mastodons that have
been extinct for some time and then this
type of sequencing that we call
next-generation sequencing was invented
next-generation sequencing allows us to
extract every bit of DNA that is
preserved within a bone or a hair or
fragment of an organism that used to be
alive and sequence all of it and in this
way we can begin to piece together the
entire genome of an extinct animal like
a mammoth or in the and earth all so the
genetic information that we extract from
these fossils can tell us a lot about
the populations that used to be alive we
can learn when they were growing when
they were declining the climate change
that is happening today is not the first
time that the earth has experienced
rapid warming and hopefully with these
data we can make more informed decisions
about how to use the limited resources
we have today to protect living and
endangered species in the face of
present-day climate change
you